hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast hunting exoplanets with a
next-generation transit survey presented
by dr. Phillip Ike Miller and dr. Colin
Coates I'm Christie jewel of lab routes
and I will be your moderator for today's
event today's educational webcast is
brought to you by lab roads and
sponsored by and/or for more information
on our sponsor please visit and/or calm
now let's get started I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them in the ask a question
box on the left side of your screen and
click send we will answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation now if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on that support tab
found at the top of your presentation
window or report your problem by using
the ask a question box this presentation
is educational and it does offer
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab and follow the process to
obtain your credit I would now like to
introduce our presenters dr. Philip Ike
Muller scientist at the DLR institute
for planetary research and dr. Colin
Coates research products manager and/or
for complete biographies on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen dr. Ike Muller and
dr. Coates you may now begin your
presentation
introduction and giving me the chance to
present the next-generation transit
survey n GTS in in this webinar so I
would like to take this opportunity to
explain a little bit about what we are
doing with the next-generation transit
survey what the next-generation transit
survey is and why I think that it's so
exciting to search for exoplanets so
before I start I would like to say a few
words about the project so we are eight
institutes collaborating in this project
it's a European collaboration mainly
from United Kingdom Switzerland Germany
and then we have a collaboration with
Chile community as our instrument is
sited at asel Paranal site in the
Atacama Desert why are we looking for
explainers exoplanets are not only are
we interested to find life or look for
aliens out there but actually what
exoplanets allow us is to take the solar
system and put it into context under few
decades ago we only knew like the
planets around the Sun only one
planetary system and of course if you
look at it you can say either it's a
unique system and there's no other
planets there or you could say of course
we expect if we see it like this in our
system then all other stars might have
similar systems so what exoplanets allow
us is to see is this really the case are
there the other systems do they look the
same as our our system or are they
completely different and of course but
they allow us also is to look into
planetary evolution at the solar system
we can only see how it is now but if we
look at for exoplanets what we can do is
we can look at stars of different age
and see how the planetary systems look
they're at different stages of their
evolution if we search for exoplanets
the parameters that are interesting for
us in regards to the evolution and
planetary system information are the
occurrence rate so that we see how many
planets are
around different types of stars how many
rocky planets do we have how many gauges
planets do we have the same thing as in
the solar system that we have the rocket
plants closer to the star and outside
these bigger gauges planets or is it
different in extrasolar systems and also
to look whether the type of star we have
stars of different temperature does this
also influences the type of planetary
systems that we see if we then go
further and have these planets detected
what of course we want to do in the end
is a goal for the future also but also
starting right now is to look into the
atmosphere of these planets so we can
basically see a planet we know there's a
planet we do follow-up observations and
try to investigate the atmosphere of
these plants to see what molecules do we
see there and in the end the final goal
of course is to see whether we see some
molecules which would hint for life on
this planet so not not aliens as we know
it from science fiction movies but a
bacterial life or something like that
so if we go into the history of
exoplanets you see now here plot where
we have the mass of the planet over the
period the orbital period so at the time
the planet takes to orbit its star and
the blue points you see there are the
planets of our solar system and you see
how this plot now populates these are
the detection over the years how we
started to detect the first plant in
1995 and then year or after year one
more plants came in and here you see the
big blob of red points adding up down
there these other planets discovered
with the Kepler mission and now we see
it again so let's concentrate we on this
green dots first so this was the first
method radial velocity method we found
very high mass planets close to the star
but out up to ten years outside orbital
period and then the red dot start
popping up these are the transiting
plants we discover with the transit
method and there we first found again
high mass planets but even closer in and
then the kepler planets come in and now
this plot populates very much also to
the low mass but as you see it's not on
the low mass right hand side where we
have the earth and Venus and Mars so
around one year we are not yet there to
detect these very small planets like
Earth so here we have now this plot is
looking a little bit different and
without this moving so I can say a few
more words here so you have this
different methods to detect these
planets and you see all already that
each method kind of can detect planets
in a different regime here so we have
these transiting plants which are of
course mostly detected closer to the
star and the radial velocity plans also
further out and then if you look at the
purple points in the right upper edge of
this applaud these are direct imaging
planets so this is basically really
planets which we have actual image of
but these are really far out because if
they're too close to their stars it
starts to bright we will not able to see
those and if it's also important to
mention that these these are mostly very
young planets where the planets are
still bright and very warm so if we go
to the different methods so the two
methods I would like to mention today
are the radio velocity method and the
transit method because these are the
methods we are using in our project so
the radial velocity method actually
takes a spectrum of the star so what we
what you can see in this plot is that
the planet is not only moving around the
star but actually the planet and the
star are moving around a common center
of gravity and that means the star that
we can see and that we can observe it's
actually moving and as you know from the
or might know from the Doppler effect is
that a moving object if it's coming
closer to you it will be blue-shifted in
further going away from you then the
light gets redshifted this is
demonstrated here with these spectra
moving left and right and by measuring
these small black lines these are
absorption lines in the in the stellar
spectrum by locating these spectral
lines very precisely we can measure the
movement of the star and from that we
can basically say okay the star is
moving some something needs to disturb
the star and this needs to be a planet
with this and this mass because this
effect is directly dependent on the mass
so combining this method with the
transit method is the best thing you can
actually do because if this man is a
ready blossom to manhood only gave you
the minimum mass depending on the
inclination that you observed but we
don't know how big the planet is we only
know the mass and now with the transit
method where the trend is a planet is
transiting as the star you see on the
right hand side a Venus transit and on
the left hand side just a yeah
artistic impression of the transit you
see that the the planet when it is in
front of the star is blocking the light
of the star the Jupiter around the Sun
would block around 1% of the stellar
light and this is something you can
easily observe but you can't imagine
that it's quite hard to find planets
that are very far out like the IRS's
because of course the earth would only
transit once per year and only if you
write directly in the line of sight and
and the problem is if you the further
you out it is already small inclinations
might get you out of line of sight and
then basically you will not see the
transit happening now if a transit is
happening we can see how much the light
is basically dimmed and we can say okay
we have to census radius and we know the
inclination and together with this with
the radial velocity method and the
transit we then can say okay we have
this in this mass and this is this
radius and so we can get directly the
mean density of the planet
so from Stella classification where we
observe the star and look at the
spectrum of the star we can determine
the mass radius and temperature of the
star and with astro seismology also the
age of the star as well if we have the
this data available then with the are we
we get the mass of the planet and the
transit gives us the radius and the
inclination and then we can make such a
plot as you see on the right hand side
where we basically gives the radius over
the map and what you see here is
different lines drawn for different
compositions so the red line at the
bottom shows the density of a pure iron
sphere so we would not expect something
more than senses and then you have
assumption like a silicate sphere
similar to the earth and then a pure
water ice sphere is a blue line and then
all above must have a very big gauges
atmosphere so this allows us now if we
combine these two methods to say
something about the star it is a rock
that we see here or is it like a Neptune
object with a gaseous atmosphere where
we don't expect life to be happening
if we then go to the next thing that we
have now found all these planets and we
know the mass the density what the next
thing we want to know is what does the
atmosphere if it has an atmosphere look
like and there I said it before we can
try to analyze the atmosphere and this
is also best possible for transiting
planets because what we can do is when
the planet is transiting its star it's
not only blocking its light but some of
the light of the star is going through
the atmosphere off the planet and this
light then gets absorbed by the planet
planet's atmosphere and then this gives
signals into the light of the star which
can tell us okay when the transit is
happening I see these and these
molecules are absorbing when the planet
is not transiting I don't see these
molecules absorbed so that tells us
these molecules where I see the
absorption lines or emission lines they
are good within the within the
atmosphere of the planet and this will
allow us to this will allow us to say
something about the atmosphere this has
already been done for gas giant planets
so we have already observed water and
atmospheres of exoplanets we have
already observed titanium oxide and
several other molecules in exoplanets
but so far only in big gauges giants not
and for now in rocky planets because
these are much smaller and of course
also the atmospheres are much smaller
and it's much harder to do these
observations but we hope with future
instruments like James wst and also with
the extremely large telescopes 30 meter
telescope set will be built up in the
future that we can do these observations
so as for now over 4000 exoplanets are
known and we have for I would say a few
hundreds we have some mean density the
thing is what you should remember is
that transit and RV method together give
us much more information than any other
detection methods and plus allows us to
say
much more about the planet than other
methods do and if we look at the nearby
planets then we can even probe the
atmosphere so now let me say a few words
about the ng TS instrument so the ng T
and telescopes is not is not one big
telescope because for the transiting
method for the to detect Jupiter around
the star the signal with one percent is
quite obvious even to detect with with a
small small telescope so the first
ground-based or very successful
ground-based project was a wasp
superboss project where they actually
use canon photon land photo lenses to do
these observations and they found a lot
of hot Jupiters around these planets
what we now want to do is to go to
smaller plants to neptune-sized super
earth sized planets and thus we use a
little bit bigger telescopes but not too
big because it if you use very big
telescopes one meter class telescopes or
even larger ones you will look further
away you will go to fainter stars and
this is not what we want to do we want
to have a wide field of view where we
have lots of bright stars in our field
of view which we can observe and find
plans around those later for the
follow-up for the radio velocity method
there's a very big telescopes and are
needed there you need much more flux for
the spectral observations but for the
photometry small telescopes are good but
you need to observe lots of sky and
therefore we use not one telescope but
12 telescopes so we have 12 completely
robotic telescopes each with an aperture
of 200 millimetres we have a specially
designed filter between 520 nanometers
and 890 nanometers which basically
blocks out the water absorption lines so
that we have as less as a variability
due to out the atmosphere in our images
as possible this is also the reason why
we are killing the Atacama Desert
we are quite high 2,600 meters
it's a dry place very dry place and very
confident atmospheric conditions there
of course also very less light
contamination from light pollution from
civilization and of course not so much
clouds but also very stable atmospheric
conditions in regards to the water vapor
in the atmosphere we use an end or I can
L camera I I think the next speaker
Colin might talk about this a little bit
more so it's a very precise instrument
with which allows us to observe a little
bit to the red so it's we are not
directly observing in the normal visible
but slightly to more shift to the red
which allows us to focus more on smaller
stars which are a little bit cooler and
a little bit redder so k-type stars with
like around four to let's say in five
thousand Kelvin a surface temperature
basically the equilibrium temperature
sect of temperature other stars we are
most interested in and the CCD is cooled
with the fourth stage perchick cooling
to minus 70 degrees Celsius to have a
low dark noise in our data as possible
so this is now our here you see our
telescopes and you see from the first
observation so this is over one hundred
fifty six nine that's basically one
field observed over a whole season over
200,000 images were taken for this one
field so we observe one field for the
whole season we have like 10 second
exposure time with this very short
readout time also CCD this allows us to
have every 12 seconds one image and then
we get can can look at the whole data
set for this whole season and look what
the noises and we get down to two
million mark in noise so much less than
10 percent which allows us to detect
smaller plants and Jupiter's of course
we can also detect hot Jupiters but we
have a precision that allows us for the
fur
time from ground to go to much smaller
planets here you see the ng Tien soda is
a special design filter you see in
orange the transmission function of the
cylinders as you can see if we basically
get everything through the filter but
have sharp cards on the right and on the
left to avoid these water absorption
lines and now I want to show you what we
want to discover so if you look at this
these are now all the exoplanets known
by now the radius / radius of the planet
over the radius of the star and you see
the line for Jupiter and Neptune and a
the diagonal lines show the the transit
depth expect to transit depth so if you
take one solar radii that's basically
the Sun and one Jupiter rounded you have
basically 1% transit depth and if you
would go for Neptune around the Sun you
have 0.1% Toronto depth so the green
area shows where we want to detect
planets and the points they're in in the
plot show known planets and as you can
see one spot and killed a ground-based
service which detected mostly
jupiter-like planets and you can see the
kepler planets down there much smaller
and have been found from space but the
unfortunate thing with the kepler planet
is that they are mostly far away and not
as good to do follow-up observations so
what we want to basically combine the
best of these two worlds and go for
smaller planets but around brighter
stars so similar to what a test also is
doing and to take now neptune-sized
plans around k-type stars but also
around solar-type stars and here you see
now a detection efficiency plot where i
show what we can actually detect and we
be injected artificial transit into our
real data and try to recover those and
we you can see we detect a transit depth
up to a 0.4
and quite easily up to a period of 16
day so of course due to the day/night
cycle we are limited to this very short
orbit planet so up to 16 days but until
now ground page service were basically
limited to like 1% 200 depths and this
you can see we are getting much further
down and even detect a short period
planners down to a 1 million mark so I
want to enter the presentation of this
survey before I come to the signed with
pointing you to the data the survey data
is actually available publicly available
on the ESO archive we are on an easel
site and either allows us to use their
infrastructure basically in
yeah basically the only thing that we
have to do for the army we have to pay
them a little bit but otherwise we only
have to give the data to the public so
we have all the data gets basically
public published one year after after
first download so we have one year
properity time but after that all the
data gets uploaded to the ESO archives
and can be downloaded by everybody who
registers there so at now like Earth
from 2016 to 2017 are now online and
there's lots of things to detect in
these lectures also aside from from
exoplanets see here on the right you see
a flare so basically as Dom was erupting
a flare so not a soul aflame a stellar
flare and this can of course be observed
also in NGS data and the high cadence of
our data allows us to really resolve
these these flares and we can even see
if there are periodic or quasi periodic
variations in the flare and these flares
sometimes have durations of less than
half an hour and of course this when
only can be seen if you have this very
short exposure time as we have and here
is just the link to the site where you
can download and look at the data so
it's easy auch Qi and if you look at the
site you have all the different projects
and right at the bottom under other you
find the ng jet server where you can
have a look at the catalog where you can
basically find all the sources and then
you can search in the light curve
catalog for the light curve for source
if you are interested in it these are
the images of what the image looks like
of n ggas and actually at the moment you
cannot download those the images are not
yet published they are not publicly
available over the ether archive patches
will come in future releases and all
these images then will be publicly
available and you can basically do the
analysis yourself you can
at a transiting or objects that are
moving through our aperture whether it's
asteroids or near-earth objects or
anything what you want to look for you
can then in the near future you can look
at all these images but of course it's a
lot of data and you need to have a good
bandwidth to download all the images so
now I would like to go come to my last
part of this presentation and that's
about the science what we have done so
far what we have published already what
we have found and our one of our
highlights is NGS 4b which was published
in 2019 recently and there was even some
press coverage about it I don't know
whether it was covered in other regions
basically I know that was very much
covered in UK and in Germany as these
are basically the our main and
Switzerland of course where we have our
main collaborations happening but maybe
you have heard about it so it was called
The Forbidden Planet I will come to that
tight a little bit later so it's a
Neptune discovered by an GTS you see the
transit depth is about 1 million mark so
it's really on this limit which we
wanted to reach so we it's a showcase
for us that we reach the precision and
that we wanted to reach and that we can
detect what we plan to and it's around
the K type star so it's really a Neptune
around the K type sound a very short
orbit
we have also read your velocity follow
up that's a curve on the right hand side
that's at the upper edge there where you
see the radial velocity points and the
curve which gives us a mass of the
planet here again the transit you see it
goes down and two to one to two million
mark so it's a really shallow transit
and of course in the as it was our first
this shallow detection
we're an so sure whether this is
actually real so what we wanted to do is
we wanted to use larger telescopes one
meter telescopes to confirm our
detection other instruments with which
we get much more photons into yeah onto
our CDs and these are now the follow-up
observations with man meter class
telescopes and what you can see is if
you compare the previous like Revenge
ETS of course its faithful it but you
compare with the single likers of these
follow-up observations with one meter
clock telescopes you can see the quality
of the energy test data and because I
mean what you can basically see is that
is really hard to do follow-up
observation confirmation as NGT has
already reaches a precision which is not
easily to be done even with larger
telescopes from ground of course the
radial velocity and the combination of
all these telescope gave us quite a
clear view on what we have here and that
the planet is real and that we have a
mass and the density and you see now
here this plot similar to what I showed
before you have the radius of planets
over the mass of the plants on the left
hand side you can see it and the red dot
is NGT s4b so it's right on the water
line so it would fit perfectly to a 100%
water planet but of course you could
imagine also that it's a rocky planet
with a gages atmosphere or small core
heavier core and then even more
atmosphere there so it's a kind of a ya
mini Neptune super earth kind of planet
and if we if you look here to the
transit depth on the right hand side
this plot again shows what we reached
with a survey so just to show how good
ng tests come NGS is compared to other
ground-based service you see these dark
black black points these are the planets
discovered from ground with others
ground-based surveys and the red dot
shows ng T s4 so you see we are really
going down in
can be detected from ground so gray dots
in the background where is the estimated
detections by test but this is only
simulated the detection so far so this
was from the proposal of the test
satellite so we will get basically into
the same regime as a test satellite from
ground and now I would like to say a few
words about why this planet actually is
called forbidden planet so if you look
at the planets that happen is covered so
far ground all planets ground-based and
from space but you look at them in
regards to their radius over the
equilibrium temperature of the planet so
that means the equilibrium temperature
of the planet is basically the
temperature that the planet gets just
from the insulation of the stellar light
so if it's closer to the star it gets
hotter if it's further why it gets
colder and here you see the temperature
and you see clear clearly two
populations you have one population in
the top left edge this is basically the
hot Jupiters that you see there and on
the right hand down what you see another
population these are basically earth
sized planets and you can see that there
in between there is a gap and although
we know that we have kind of a
observational bias for the hot Jupiters
from the ground-based service we know
from kepler where we don't have these
bars that actually this gap is real so
there is actually some a plant or they
are barriers in this diagram on the left
side where you see the word sub Jovian
desert where actually are much less
planets than in other regions of this
diagram and basically what we see there
the planets that have been found there
are all operating they are basically
dissolving there through due to the sea
high insulation from the star the Atmos
is basically blown away and here we see
the radius of equilibrium temperature
but if you look at the next plot which
shows a mass over the orbital period
which is basically the same so it's a
how far to start a planet is away from
the star you see that in this region
where NGT s4b has been discovered
basically no other planet can be found
you see here now much less plants and in
the plot before and that's basically
because of the kepler planet lots of
those are so far away that we have
problems determining their mass and we
can only say something about their
radius and that's why you see much less
planet here but even though you can see
that you have lots of planets down words
in the super earth regime and lots of
planets upwards in the hot Jupiter
regime but in between for the hot
Neptune's we actually are missing
planets we don't find these planets and
ngg s4b is one of the planets that is
right there
another interesting planet i just want
to mention shortly is ngg s5b it's a
very low density planet so it's a
inflated planet it's very large so here
we have a much nicer like roof as you
can see on the top left a bottom left
side and there you can basically see
that we have a clear transit there 2% so
it's like 10 times deeper than for the
other four n ggas for B but when we try
to measure the mass we actually see the
mass is not that different so it's a low
mass but with a large planet low mass
large planet so low density and if you
look now here on all the planets
discovered so far so again this is how
all planets discovered and what is
plotted here is the density of the
planets over the equilibrium temperature
and what you can see is that n ggas 5 P
is basically on the lower edge of what
seems to be possible so they are not
much more plants that are at such a low
density and
there's this is of course also giving us
insights into a planet formation planet
evolution and all these planets will
give us hints in what is possible how
does what what mechanisms are working in
the background and what do we need to
explain with this mechanism so what we
do normally then is we look at models
that are out there we try to see whether
these models can explain the planets
that we observe the populations that we
observe and then modify the theories of
planet formation to find out whether
they are actually able to describe what
we find in observations so to summarize
this now my talk and I want just to say
a few words as a basically go home
message so NGT has a small adventure
telescope system with twelve independent
telescopes it is detecting exoplanets
using the transit method with a radial
velocity method we then afterwards to
follow-up observations to determine
their mass we are probing with the NGT
as a sub Jovian desert where only few
plants have been found so far and this
is important too to find out what
mechanisms are working in the background
what is causing these sub Jovian desert
what is causing this evolution or what
is driving the evolution of planetary
systems and as a last point the light
curves in high cadence are available and
if you are interested in looking at them
you are more than welcome to to download
the data look at the data and dig deep
into it and see what you can find
so I'm with this I I want to thank you
for listening to me and now I would like
to hand over to Colin who will continue
with a presentation on end or
Thank You Philip for that fantastic
presentation so in my part I want to
sort of in keeping with the theme of
angle Tyler discovery using transit
methods I wanted to focus more on to
talking about the types of enabling
detectors which are use in these types
of studies so the title I've chosen here
is detective solutions for large sky
surveys and occultation studies but
occupations you know could be could be
projected to talk about you know any
type of detector which which looks for
photometric variability
so
is break it down into it what we need to
image more of the sky first of all so
generally we're talking about larger
format larger area detectors you know
typically fairly high resolution
detectors as well so what we have an
outdoors lineup in this regard is is a
series of detectors ranging from what
what's probably been our biggest seller
over the years is these four megapixel
2k 2k C CDs which have been used in a
variety of exoplanet programs up even
more recently to six k6k devices so and
often then enlarged sky surveys you're
not just using one detector you're using
as you've just seen an array of
detectors as well now for anybody who
wants to then you know break out from
the arrays and just start to use one
massive detective coursers anybody who's
looked into sensor purchases before for
building their own cameras would know
there's a somewhat nonlinear
relationship between sensor area and
price so that now tends to be the very
much practical trade-off when when
considering the very large detectors now
when we come to occupations or as I said
generally photometric variability you
might want to think about different time
scales so a nice way to break it down is
to think about what what typically see
CDs have been used for in terms of time
skills variability would be ranging from
anywhere from tens of seconds or even 10
seconds up to ours or of acquisition
time and for the longer exposures of
course you'd have they need very very
good cooling of the sensor and there's
also a presence of very good red and
near-infrared enhanced options in the
CCD ranges which have some relevance and
sellable ready alluded to some of that
during his presentation
what more interestingly in recent years
there's been a growth of a new in a way
new CMOS has been around for a long time
but what we call scientific CMOS is more
relatively recent and we launched this
back as a technology back in 2007 and
smaller format devices
and feminist from an astronomy point of
view we would recommend it for
photometric and astrometric variability
anywhere from milliseconds up to tens of
seconds as a general rule so we're
covering between CCDs & Seymour's quite
a large time range of variability time
skills and interestingly I'll mention
this a little bit later on as well we're
on the verge of launching an even larger
format s CMOS detector which is getting
up to the sort of detector sizes that
people are more affiliated with with the
very large CC DS so we'll come to that
in a few minutes
so let's step back and look at the deep
cool CCDs
a little bit more detail so as a sailor
they're perfect for measuring
photometric astrometric variability over
tens of seconds to ours typical science
usages have been in not just exoplanet
CCA's are used very often for a while
feel respect wide field spectroscopic
surveys and even applications like
gravitational lensing
so an Anders range our flagship deep
cool CCDs is called the icon family and
there's a number of different model
types within this range but generally
that they have a lot in common in terms
of that they would all cool down to
minus 100 degrees C irrespective of the
sensor size especially when you read out
nice and slowly if you're not in a rush
to you know read out you can take long
exposures and a company that was with a
slow read out then you avail of some
very low noise and high dynamic range
capabilities they're all back
illuminated so they were all maxed at
over 90% quantum efficiency as I
mentioned some other more or what's
called deep depletion and offer very
good near-infrared response as well and
they all avail of a permanent vacuum
enclosure so that that's important not
just for the cooling I've put a very
important point of relevance there
minimal downtime means that you expect
not to have to reap ump out that sensor
and soldier over time so the cameras
designed us to stay on-site observing
away and to minimize any sort of you
know postal service time
so the example I'm showing here is
called the icon l which has been used at
ng TS and it's based on the e2b ccd
forty to forty four point two megapixel
device thirteen point five micron pixels
and over more recent years we've been
selling more and more of these larger
area ETV devices the example here is the
ccd two three one eighty four so it's a
16-point lead megapixel device so it's
just greater than 4k 4k with 15 micron
pixel size and we still pull that down
to minus 100 degrees using
thermoelectric cooling
so interestingly across these are these
CCD cameras the I quenelle and icon
Excel you can get these deep depletion
curbs so I'm showing a couple of them
here in the red and the blue quantum
efficiency profiles so as I mentioned
they're great for for enhancing and they
read under infrared sensitivity so that
can't have a lot of relevance and
astronomy especially for things like
exoplanet studies because as Phillip
mentioned ngd injured here's has been
availing of these types of red and
Hounds detectors it's one of the
differences between an GDS and some
previous generation exoplanet programs
and not then enhances them for they were
focusing their are focusing on K type
stars with surface temperatures between
4,000 5,000 K was mentioned so typically
that's the trend as you go towards
smaller and smaller dwarf type talents
then you have a lower surface
temperature they tend to to emit more
across the near infrared and even into
the shortwave infrared wavelength range
so you feel better you feel more of
Detectives are optimized for for those
we have length ranges and there's a lot
of benefits to that for focusing on
these on these smaller planets but
they're much more populous in our Milky
Way
they tend the planets are unintended how
closer and more frequent orbital periods
and just simply the relative size
difference between a small star and a
planet means you have a greater relative
terms of depth so all of this increases
your your test statistics of detection
of exoplanets
so just a few examples are super wasp
was one of the first generation
wide-angled planets search programs
which use an array of icon elves we
taught a lot today about about the N GTS
which is using the near infrared and
house injection which is actually a tube
you have said their transit and RV is
being used Minerva as well about Hopkins
Arizona is another example using transit
and RV and then more recently the icon
excel the 4k 4k device has been used at
in the Antarctic in this Chinese program
the Antarctic bright star Survey
telescope
so let's move on to large area
scientific CMOS technology as I
mentioned it's a more it's a relatively
recent introduction to the market and it
first started out in smaller devices and
the technology was really introduced
first of all primarily for microscopy
markets rather than astronomy but there
actually has been some good usages of
the first generations of scientific CMOS
even smaller platform devices in
astronomy programs so I've summarized
the timescales again here because that's
quite important endeavor engineering
these from CCD solutions I've said
they're perfect for measuring
photometric or astrometric variability
across milliseconds to tens of seconds
so if you remember I was recommending
deep school or deep cooled slow radar
CCDs for tens of seconds or two hours
well here I'm covering the kind of lower
faster time range and these are just
some typical applications I've listed
here in the earth object detection a
range of different occultation type
studies could be characterizing the
Kuiper belt and even from the tens of
seconds exposures could still have a
home with an exoplanet monitoring and
it's also an interesting technology for
for lucky and speckle imaging for
Atmospheric freezing but over a larger
field of view that done is achievable
done with adaptive optics from
ground-based sights
so the technology itself emit
distinguishes itself from CCDs primarily
and its capability to achieve low noise
with fast reader normally when you read
out a CCD fast because everything is
done very sequentially in a CCD it
really increases the read noise there's
lots of parallel readout on our CMOS
that hasn't some challenges which
fortunately are surmountable but it also
is one of the enablers to helping you
keep the read noise in check so you can
basically get noise levels that are
characteristic of a very very slow
readout CCD but a massively faster frame
rates and readout speeds so that's the
key benefit that then further enabled
you to make high-resolution sensors and
still read them as fast with low noise
so the architecture differs in others
there's no charge transfer as during
readout as you would normally associate
with a CCD you know charge is not
transferred from row to row pixel to
pixel in radar through a common read out
architecture there's a lot more parallel
rewrite and you don't have the same
charge transfer mechanism an important
practical benefit of scientific CMOS
also for astronomy is that you do not
require a mechanical shutter so that
that's often a very attractive thing for
an astronomy solution that as I
mentioned downtime is a bad thing
mechanical shutters are are you know
have a finite lifetime they don't go on
indefinitely
the typical have they typically have a
cycle time typical cycle time associated
with them so at some stage ever used
frequently enough you expect them to
seal so getting rid of like mechanical
shutter is a good practical solution to
reducing downtime on sight
I mentioned there in the summary a
high-dynamic-range mood for scientific
samosas it's an interesting technology
and not the pixels the pixels
architecture itself is designed to
enable you to do something that you
don't normally associate with CCDs and
see cds normally you're normally you're
either optimizing and through a choice
of an amplifier again to be good at Lu
noise and therefore weak signal
detection or to to maximize the sill
pixel well depth but that will sacrifice
the reed noise so that then they're
optimized for for brighter objects so
scientific CMOS in general avail of this
multi Gihon architecture which which
lets you stick together in real time
across a not per pixel across a number
of of Gihon dynamic range areas so
basically that means you can you can
harness the lowest noise and the maximum
well depth in one single scan you don't
need to optimize and make a choice up
front to do one or the other
so I thought I'd throw in this recent
example if not if not an occultation
study but I thought it was a good recent
and relevant example of high scientific
CMOS and this is just one of the first
generation detectors not even such a
massive field of view but it has been
used in a good interesting application
which justifies you know really quite
fast for your mates
so this Delhi otter program at the
National Observatory of Athens and as
ISA Saunders has been used to monitor
the size and frequency distribution of
objects in the earth neighborhood does
this basically by looking for very very
weak impact flashes on the moon's
surface so it needs to have a sensitive
detector low noise detector to pick up
these very dim events but it also needs
to be able to operate but you know that
the requirement for the program was
greater than 20 frames a second so
they've been using the this xyla s CMOS
camera at 30 frames a second in fact the
camera can operate up to 100 frames a
second and they reported this back in
2018 and at that time they have
monitored more than 55 near-earth object
impacts on the lunar surface in fact
they've been using two xyla cameras
simultaneously in two optical bound
passes the R and I bands
so more recently we've been moving on to
launch larger area scientific theme of
detectors the first generations were 22
millimetres diagonal and sorry 19 and 22
millimetres diagonal and last year run
about this time last year we launched a
thirty two millimeter diagonal version
which is also back illuminated so not
only has it given as a larger field of
view to play with the see more sky it's
also boosted to QE up to a greater than
ninety percent
and then what we're launching actually
very soon is the latest generation
scientific CMOS never this this has been
purpose designed for for astronomy it's
called Baal or Baal or zania marish
mythology as a huge one-eyed giant with
a single massive eye and as for hit but
like Cyclops and this is basically our
very large area s CMOS platform so this
will be a 70 millimeter sensor diagonal
it's a sixteen point nine megapixel
device with 12 micron pixels three
electrons read noise so still maintains
a very low rate noise but I can still do
this even though there's lots and lots
of pixels there we can still read it out
up to 52 frames per second now not all
applications need such such vast frame
rates but it's there if you need it but
the key thing is it still does it even
if you're using much longer exposure
times even ten seconds you can still
read out and about 18 or 19 milliseconds
which makes it very distinct from C CDs
so it'll be front illuminated with 60
percent quantum efficiency it'll have
that same kind of high dynamic range
multi key and architecture in it to get
the loon eyes on the field well Devon
one scan and it will be a vacuum device
again and all the benefits that come
with that so basically this is combining
very large format and fast variability
capability
you
actually shipped a couple of early
cameras to a lead customer this is a the
D test solar telescope is under
construction no do for first light in a
relatively relatively near future
we've shed the number of Baal or 4k 4k
CMOS detectors to to the decays program
for use across a number of different
instruments so I'll finish just by
giving a comparison an exposure time
range that is more typical of exoplanet
study so I've chosen 10 seconds here so
we're not going to 54 frames per second
but if but let's just choose some more
modest of 10 frames per second so the
issue if you're trying to do faster
throughput measurements of any nature
with the C CDs is to get low noise you
have to rely slowly even a 4k 4k CCD
with 4 output ports you have to slow it
down to basically 100 kilohertz pixels
per port and that that gives you a 45
second readout to rewrite the entire 4k
4k so that gives you basically a 55
second cycle time and you have to also
factor in shutter open shutter tools
there now if you try to do the same sort
of thing
with a scientific CMOS of 4k 4k you can
take this 10 second exposure time but
your readout is now massively reduced
don't it like eighteen point five
milliseconds which means you can
basically and there's no shutter open or
close either you can immediately start
your next exposure right after that so
you've got a vastly reduced cycle time
even in that sort of more modest frame
rate applications so ultimately you can
use this to give you a throughput
measurement boost and I can't be
important for some programs now I
mentioned even as an interesting thought
the CMOS there is a front illuminated
detector with about 60 percent quantum
efficiency so even if you try to make
that effectively as sensitive as a
Backson detector by by increasing your
exposure length by 50 percent then
you're still only increasing up to a
cycle time of 15 seconds so in this
example here it'll still be you know on
a light per like signal to noise basis
it'll still be 3.5 times faster
throughput that down the equivalent CCD
there's an interesting thought
I'm going to leave it there and open the
floor to questions for Philip or myself
so thank you very much for your
attention
I structure item Euler and doctor coat
for your informative presentation we
will now start the live Q&A if you have
any questions you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on that ask the
question box located on the far left of
your screen and we'll answer as many
questions we have time for okay we've
got some great questions coming in let's
start pressure I feel ER let's start
this one with you houses in GPS compared
to tes s
so TAS is a NASA satellite that launched
last year so it's a smell basically its
first year of observations done and we
are also the first data analyze first
plants have been found so it's of course
a space-based mission so in regard of
limiting transit Delta gets to better
results than we have it can get smaller
planets it has some so so what ng chance
has advantage in is the spatial
resolution so one pixel for the test
satellite is twenty arc seconds this is
problematic if you have many stars
nearby to find out which stars actually
in causing the signal is it one of the
brighter stars and you actually see a
planet or is it one of the neighboring
faint stars and then the signal actually
that you see quite a shallow transit is
actually much deeper and it's actually
caused by a background eclipsing binary
star or something like that so ng chance
can then do follow-up observations and
actually we started to do a program now
also to complement it test observations
look at candidate of tests and find out
whether we can say something about those
and help to identify planets identity
planet candidates that have been
identified with the test satellite right
otherwise of course test is a quite
useful useful instrument I mean it's
covering the whole sky over its duration
and we will get lots of nice results out
of it and but we still see quite a good
niche for NGS to continue and to
contribute to the exoplanet science
thank you let's move on to our next
question now for how long will ng TS
continue
so ng TS was originally planned for
three years duration observation
duration and actually we started 2016
with the nominal operation and actually
so basically 16 17 18 we would have
already been done and this already tells
you that there seems to be a
prolongation and actually we will
continue now for 3 more years so this is
now fixed so we will have now 2019 2021
and after that we will have to negotiate
again with either whether we can still
operate it and whether we all of course
also find the money to operate the
system as : also said I mean there's
some things with for example shutters
which need to be taken care of there can
only operate so and so much and with
this very short exposure times we
basically need to travel to Chile like
every three months or so to replace some
of the shutters and this of course takes
time of people a work time and also
costs money and this needs them to be
looked at again in three years so for
now we have three more years and then we
will see
thank you there's another question
that's come in presumably and GTS images
show distortion across the field of view
how much distortion do you see in terms
of the aspect aspect ratio of the PSS
and do you account for it in your
photometry so actually the optical setup
of NGS is quite good so although we have
a quite a big field of views the
distortion is limited so this is also
very important for us as we want to have
all the stars always on the same pixels
and so too much distortion changing
awesome or might be changing over
tonight depending on where we actually
look like would introduce too much and
too much additional noise so we are
quite happy that we have not so much
distortion so in the middle centre of
the field of view we get basically and
full width half maximum of the PSF of
about 1.7 pixels and this is a still so
below 2 pixels around 2 pixels at the
edges also of the CCD
okay let's go for our next question we
have time for a few more
our updates or improvement plan for and
GTS
so the improvement on the hardware side
on are not planned so there's so we have
to instrument as it is now I mean there
are discussions about whether we can get
rid of the shutters there's software
solutions which allow you to do
observation without shutter and then
basically calculate back this is easy
additional delusion you get through if
your exposure while you read out but and
this is one thing that's in discussion
but it's not clear whether we will apply
this at any point but what we are doing
all the time is looking at our software
to handle the noise that we have in the
data to handle also the noise that is
not coming from the system but it's
coming directly from the stars the stars
show sometime additional signals and of
course you want to get rid of this to
have the best possible detection
efficiency for the planets and also I
mean you find normally lots and lots of
planets and what you want to do is you
want to limit or you'll find lots of
love of candidates right and you want to
limit the false positive rate and
there's also a machine learning
algorithms that you can implement to
basically improve your detection
algorithms and this is what we are
working on
thank you now I'm going to bump over to
dr. Coates for this question um dr.
Coates who's you do deep depletion see
CDs have hired our courage
yet typically they need to actually it's
a function of you you with a deep
depletion pixel you're basically just
creating a greater path lengths of
silicon through which the photon must
travel to get so it enhances the
probability of detection of the photon
especially in the near-infrared but the
downside is there's just more there's
more silicon in there to create thermal
charge which appears just like a photo
electron so there's all the more
relevance for for for cooling of deep
relation C cities to keep the dark
current especially for long exposures to
a minimum normally I mean it really is a
function of exposure time as well dark
hardness electrons per pixel per second
if you're going to use you know 30
minute exposures or something that it's
a very very relevant consideration if
you're closer to 10 seconds or 20
seconds 30 seconds and it's not nearly
as impacting because it is kind of
buried in the read noise limit anyway
but it's certainly a consideration and
and also when applying cooling you have
to consider some minor trade-offs in
quantum efficiency because there is
something to consider there when you
cool a CCD especially a deep depletion
you have to consider what happens in our
near-infrared range to the quantum
efficiency curve because cooling can
actually deplete your QE profile in the
red so there's a bit of a bounce to be
struck so a lot needs to be considered
and it very much depends on your
acquisition times
thank you for that and we do have time
for one more question but I'd like to
remind the audience that any questions
we did not have time for today and
questions that come in during the
on-demand period they will be addressed
by our speakers via the contact
information that you provided at the
time of registration okay our final
question today
do you have also a s CMOS cameras with
back illuminated sensors
yes so yes what preciate I went through
my sides quite fast so this might have
been missed one of the slides that I
that I showed talked about a CMOS
detector called the Marana no we lost
out almost one year ago and it's the
detector I mentioned how to have a
thirty two millimeter diagonal and it
happens to be back illuminated so the
dots in terms of quantum efficiency the
most sensitive err CMOS in our portfolio
but I did make a point at the end it
depends on why you feel you know why the
program needs back illumination if it's
to reduce the exposure to if it's to
achieve a certain signal-to-noise target
with a reduced exposure time and higher
throughput of measurement then it is
worth bearing in mind my last slide as
well which says that with CC DS you know
you um you have quite a long readout
time that you have to factor into the
overall cycle time and measurement
throughput so when comparing two C CDs
you can actually achieve some very very
impressive throughputs even with a front
illuminated CMOS just by compensating
with a longer exposure time but still
availing of the practically next to
nothing readout time by comparison so
thank you
thank you very much dr. Ike Muller and
doctor coat no do either of you have any
final comment for our audience
No
no thanks No thank you very much for
everyone's attention that's but much
appreciated thank you yes and we thank
you both for your time today I'd also
like to thank our audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions and I'd like to also thank lab
Roach and our sponsor and or for writing
today's educational webcast
now this webcast can be viewed on two
bands and laberd's will excuse you a
mail when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's light event you will now be
redirected to the registration page for
our next and or webinars nanometer
accuracy
distance measurements between
fluorophores
at the single molecular level and this
is presented live on August 13th by dr.
Nico Stormin and dr. Marcin Bartowski we
hope to see you there have a great day
and good bye for now
five